[Music]
okay let's get right to the jokes uh
this is true last week i nearly heard a
habitat heart a hat attack oh my god
sorry i nearly had a heart i heart oh my
god um last week i heard a heart of ha
had a heart uh last week i got my heart
on caught in a hammock there we go ah
ah
i couldn't get it out
and i couldn't get it out but that's
fine because whenever you're faced with
a life or death situation like that it
forces you to look back on life you get
nostalgic but that can be dangerous
because sure we have fond memories that
fill us with joy
but i also have regrets
like when i was 13
i farted in a mayonnaise jar
and i recapped it
and i put it in the refrigerator
and soon afterwards i watched my
grandmother
assemble a ham cheese and mayonnaise
sandwich
and then i watched her eat it
but i also have regrets
things i wish i didn't do
don't clap it's not that funny
uh
but one regret i do have is uh i bought
my nephew a kite for christmas yeah i
will never ever buy another child a kite
for christmas because kites are like
smoke signals to pedophiles all right
they know what's on the other end of the
string okay
it's called dinner well i don't know if
they're eating the children it doesn't
matter
i gotta look that up
but what's interesting is i sent my
friend adam uh a text and then my friend
adam texted me back and the text that
adam wrote me read call me in 10 minutes
or else i'm having a shower
yeah adam doesn't really know how to
threaten people if you think about it i
mean think about it you're going to have
to threaten
moves from you guys you're going to move
yeah you're going to be because i'll
move you to the back just up here yeah
and if you don't know are you together i
don't know if i should start again oh
okay um excuse me we're gonna move this
group
excuse me yep hi sorry
what are you doing oh i'm just moving
some people trying to arrange the crowd
for the segment okay yeah well
i'm trying to work here so oh me too so
we have a lot in common i guess
all right no i i don't think you
understand like i think what i'm doing
is a little bit more important than what
you're doing right now all right is it
okay yeah pedophile joke i'm trying to
move them so that i can
have it
what i'm doing is actually i think do
you think this is easy i think it's very
easy do you think what i'm doing you
think this is easy you think this is
guys guys guys
guys
guys
guys you're both being incredibly
unprofessional yeah and i don't even
think we have ushers yeah we don't that
is yeah
i mean for god's sake show some maturity
oh i'm sorry
do you think this is easy
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen please welcome
sarah chuck
[Music]
hey sarah are you promoting anything uh
yes
actually i am oh that's great but we're
all out of time
okay wow
ladies and gentlemen huh i've been
hosting a late night show for 20 years
now and i think i have to say john dore
is the best comic i have ever seen round
of applause
john doerr is a genius i don't know why
john doerr isn't the host of conan well
that's our show i want to thank my guest
john dore
amanda seifried yes
adam pally sarah chalk
andy richter jimmy vavino and the basic
cable band
goodnight everyone and finally
all kidding aside round of applause for
the real conan o'brien
[Applause]